kagia summer K summer romantic which is
the third season of KM the ending
essentially they rating no it's still
going going it's still going but there
was a big ended no it hasn't ended what
the [__] the manga is ending right the
manga's ending yeah the manga's ending
but this was a season where with there a
big climactic moment happened in the
anime oh yes and uh yeah I you put it at
11 on your list if you had a list
be close to it bit lower bit higher I I
think it's an incredibly solid modern
romance show for sure because I feel
like a lot of problem with like modern
romance especially ones after like 2010
I just feel they kind of like got into a
formula that was just kind of overdone
and even if it was a fresh formula or an
interesting formula they didn't really
like deliver on it to make it worth
sitting around for like I I call it I
personally call that the hor Mia effect
where like it's like horia it started
off with this like really like unique at
the time concept when it came out that
was like oh okay this is like kind of a
straightforward yet like easy to
understand concept I can follow along
with it you're not about to come out
with the hot and then it just kept
[__] dragging on and on and on and
there was nothing that happened okay hot
okay that is not apparently it's a hot
that is that is not kagio summer though
KAG no no I'm not saying that I thought
I thought you were about I thought you
about to say
yo this is why K summer was good because
it didn't do that it actually kept you
interested because it added so many
fresh things throughout the story that
is also very easy to understand I I have
a question why do we generally tend to
hold in higher regard action adventure
shows as opposed to romance cuz I
imagine on this list it's very heavily
stacked towards Adventure or yeah action
shows because we have monkey brain and
we think that that's better and uh we
want see big man punch other big man big
man big man punch but like there are
there are a lot of romance show I mean I
see the treat
fruit none of these are in the top 10
yeah yeah that's true I I kagia Sama I
am very very glad that it exists uh
because I feel like kagios Sama is one
of those uh few romances that got a
monum of popularity where a lot of
romance anime they don't even enter like
the echelon of like popular
consensus I feel like K Su that um is it
my favorite Romance of all time probably
not top 25 of favorite of best romances
no no no of uh anime for
you uh I mean this is going into like
personal uh I did like I think I've just
grown out of high school romances out of
everything I think kagama is definitely
my favorite High School romance I I'm
more of an adult romance kind of guy
right now I want adult romance more
well I did I did appreciate one thing I
did appreciate about this season of kism
especially is that the way that they
decided to go about the romance was
definitely done in a more sensible and
mature way where like even mature
Watchers of the show could appreciate it
whereas I feel like a big like thing
with a lot of high school romances is
that it's very difficult for I guess
older audiences to like really get
themselves into because either the way
that the romance is done and is
represented is very like Anonymous with
like that age group or it's just
something that they can't really appeal
to anymore because they are now older
whereas I feel K kind of straddled the
line between those two fan bases in a
pretty tasteful way so yeah I'm I'm
pretty happy with this let let me say
like this if kagios Sama came out when I
started watching anime this would be
this would be my favorite Romance of all
time like like like that's like straight
up this like I know I know why people
love this and watching the biggest thing
that surprised me going into like the
second and third season seon was uh so
it starts off and kind of like the the
hook is that it's a romance but it's
kind of like a Death Note kind of
romance right and that's like that's
like he he funny death note Mind Games
in a romance and you know that hooks you
in and then season 2 and season 3 has
some amazing [__] character writing
and it gives depth these characters
where I wasn't watching this to see this
much depth and this many developments
happen which each of the characters and
that just kind of like surprised you out
of nowhere and then that's what that's
why people really really like kagi
summer um the only Nerf for it for it
for me is that I am now 33 and I'm still
watching High School romances and they
just do not the same as they used to do
and that is not a slight on kagio summer
that is just that is a war against the
entire genre that that is just a me
thing that is just a me thing that's fa
so personally would I put it in my top
50 no but as it's understandable yeah
but like I said if if I if I was 18
years old 16 years old I can't remember
how long when when did I start watching
anime [__] yeah [__] 15 16 years
old this would definitely be up there
yeah yeah uh speaking of the most my
animist show ever legendary show
legendary show this is hero this is the
uh yes I I do watch anime I'm just not
an I'm not just an anime fan anime fan
it's an OVA so it never add on TV yeah
no oh wow it was just it was being
released in DVD from kept
alive well look at the earring it
started in January
1988 and finished in March
1997 is it fully completed yeah it's
fully completed okay um I have not
finished watching legend of the galactic
heroes I'm going to say the most [__]
my anime list anime man thing ever I
[__] love this
[__] what did you think I was going to
[__] on it you you like I'm going to say
the most anime man thing ever I just had
that [__] Robert Downey Jr like oh my
God oh my God thank you Joey's not going
to say hot this is an incredibly
well-written show is there a new version
of this yeah yeah I think I voiced in a
dub oh really I'm pretty sure I voiced
one in one of the how do you not
remember yeah dude it was so fast they
were just like can you just be some uh
guy who just said something in a bar I
like four lines in a bar but I think
that's [__] dope to say you been in
Legend of the GL I think I'm in Legend I
I I I don't know which I have no idea
maybe someone can tell me if I am I'm
I'm I'm definitely in one of the dubs
though but yeah legend of the galactic
yeah but legend of the galactic heroes
is by far one of the best space operas
ever written I think just does it hold
up today oh incredibly should I should I
watch it should I okay here's uh here's
maybe a hot take from me um I think you
should just watch the Remake is it is it
good uh it's very good I haven't seen
the Remake it's incredible is it
completely finished no oh that's that's
the big problem uh I I
it's it's actually funny I watch legends
of galactic heroes I go about I think
like halfway through or something
stopped watching it because I was like
ah I I get to watch the Remake caught up
to the remakes and it's it's it's
actually about the same point in the
remakes which which is where I stopped
the original so I don't have any
opinions on like the second half of
Legends of the galactic heroes but it is
it is just incredible writing I don't
know what to say but can you say
confidently that it deserves the 12th
spot if you haven't finished it it
deserves to be higher what would put
this in my top 10 damn is that good it's
it's like this feels like the Citizen
Cane of anime it kind of is it is but
like I everyone says it's good no one
can say a bad thing about it I think the
one thing I really respect about legend
of the galactic heroes is that it's a
show that's really not afraid to take
its time but in a way where you because
there's a lot of characters in this show
obviously as well cuz it's such a long
show but like at the end of the show you
feel like you know every single detail
about every single character and again
like in in I can't believe I'm going to
do this but in the same way as Gintama
you it it bro you are literally a m
anime Lista bro in the same way as
Gintama in the sense of it feels like
the most natural progression of how
things can go and characters just make
sense I you like have to have this on
your if you're an if you're a big user
of my anime list this is probably like a
skill check on your profile oh no I know
what I'm talking look I got it I got it
are you a level one anime fan or a level
100 anime like gint in the same way I
imagine now actually cuz you said it
referenc a l of shown jum humor perhaps
it's more of a like look look I'm an
anime fan G is absolutely an anime show
for anime fans yeah okay go ahead uh I
feel like the real appeal of like legend
of the galactic heres it might not be
something as like cuz it doesn't have
like a lot of action it's something that
is very political very deep very dense
like it's a very very it's not something
you could just cas watch you need to be
you need to be invested in this you need
to be invested in it but no subway
service on the side no subway service on
the side uh the thing that's incredible
to me about Legends of galactic heroes
is that when I watch it it almost
doesn't feel like I'm watching a
fictional story feels real it almost
feels like I am watching a history
documentary cuz that's what it feels
like right that's cool um it feels like
that's all you had to say I'll watch it
now documentary I watch
it when you said when you that exactly
it almost feels like you're watching
history like unfold of a certain
timeline where something happens and
then every like this knock on effect on
its world makes total [__] sense and
you see different storylines of
different leaders different dictators
different people within the history of
this world things the best way I can say
is things happen and people make
decisions and this affects everything
that happens in the timeline of this
world kind of like history does you when
like you know when you read about hey
this guy called genas Khan just appeared
and then he decided to do this and then
this had a knock going enough it's it
kind of feels like that kind of like
real life it's it's in a lot of ways
similar to Dune where like the universe
yeah the universe surrounding the story
is so succinct and so like well thought
out yeah it's so well thought out that
when one thing as G said it's like a
chain reaction when one event happens in
the story
and these characters react it makes so
much sense to the viewer they're like oh
of course they would react this one of
my favorite scenes okay last thing I say
one of my favorite scenes in anime is in
Legend the galactic heroes where it's
just two these two characters have just
been that have just been built up for
like Seasons upon seasons and then they
finally get to meet I know exactly
you're talking they sit down for a coup
of see and I'm like holy [__] this is
this is [__] incredible and they just
and they just baate philosophy and I'm
just like this this is sick this is sick
I that's why it's the
go all right's like in fate you like
that scene in fate too oh when when
they're walking around his CLE uh when
they're all sitting down drinking yeah
but this is this is like imagine that
scene but when you've had like 50
episodes worth the
build higher is what we're saying it
deserves it